[Music]
all right here we go
everybody thousands of people
contributed years to this historic
moment
ladies and gentlemen it's time for blue
origin's first human flight
godspeed first crew of new shepard let's
light this candle
t minus 16 guidance internal
t-minus 10 9 8
seven six five four
command engine start two one
go jeff go marco wally go oliver you are
going for space
[Music]
oh my goodness listen to the roar of the
be3 engine we are just about to pass
through max q maximum dynamic pressure
that was when the stresses on the
vehicle are at their maximum
max cube max q is confirmed
beautiful burn on that be3 engine
liquid hydrogen and
liquid oxygen as the propellants it's a
nice
not just clean in terms of uh
beautifully performing but
what comes out of it it's steam right
to see to see the the
the glow of the of the engine underneath
the rocket just under
our shoulders and to know that we've got
a crew that is going to space
it it just feels different doesn't it
gary
it is totally different
all right you can follow along of course
the speedometer in the bottom left
the altimeter in the middle of the
screen there
so far appears to be a nominal flight
all right coming up here on mikko main
engine cut off that will be followed
shortly
by separation and at that point after
separation we're gonna
let the astronauts unbuckle and take in
the freedoms of zero g
there is miko main engine cut off
a beautiful shot down the new shepherd
rocket
look at that view
unreal
awaiting separation here
and here we are you can start to see
stand by you're going to see the
separation of the capsule from the
booster itself
[Music]
oh
and there we go our astronauts have
passed the carmen line
at about 328 thousand feet continuing
their ascent
you see the two vehicles there
when the speed hits zero you know that
they've hit apogee they're
maximum altitude and you hear their
happen
quite an experience
all my instincts are fast okay have the
[ __ ] back
yep
one one-minute warning
well there you have it greg besos and
his crew
heading into space or to the edge of
space we have to be clear don't we greg
we are watching them uh head up there
but this entire flight
is only gonna take around 11 minutes it
is that they'll be on their way back
down
um uh pretty quickly actually and i
think with that that that sound we were
hearing was sound coming from that uh
that capsule and the the celebrations
and you could hear the excitement and
look at those shots looking back down
from from that craft that celebration
that they they reached the edge of space
66 miles up was the uh was the planned
uh height they would reach they would
have those three or four minutes of
weightlessness i think that's what we
were listening to actually
we hope to see pictures from there at
some point from inside that capsule as
well of those moments as we did with
richard branson
but what's happening now is they begin
their journey down the rocket booster
the thing that took them up there that
we saw that will land
uh pretty much back where it uh it took
off that's of course one of the
the new uh features of these these
launches that the rockets are reusable
and then the capsule will also enter the
earth atmosphere and will come down
uh under parachutes and and land pretty
softly back
here in the in the desert and um and
they will complete
something at the moment it seems to be
going entirely according to plan a very
smooth
uh liftoff as you heard from mission
control everything nominal
everything exactly as they expected and
those those celebrations
uh as um as they made it to that height
so on the left you're looking at that
view from the capsule
on the right um uh that that uh that
return
to earth and and all four of them
will officially be classed as as
astronauts having made that journey
and i call for just for jeff bezos uh it
will be the realization of something
that started 52 years ago today he said
when he watched
neil armstrong and buzz aldrin walk on
the surface of the moon
and choosing today uh as the moment to
make his own journey that he dreamed
about for so long
space journalist kate arkless gray has
been watching along with us
as well uh kate i mean i'm sure you've
watched more of these than i
have but you never fail to hold your
breath
um as a rocket launches and we can just
see them or the pictures just
cut out they're just touching down it
seems like this was a successful
maiden voyage for jeff bezos and his
crew
so yes the booster has just landed now
we're just waiting for the capsule which
uh contains our
our new astronauts uh there it is it's
just uh floating down so the next big
thing we're watching out for is the
parachutes
so once the parachutes come out that
will help to slow them down
so that when they when they do hit the
ground they're only traveling at around
one or two miles an hour
and just before they land there'll be
some retro thrusters
so you'll probably see a big kick up of
dust and dirt and that's not because
they've
smacked into the ground at such a a fast
speed
but it's it's these thrusters that just
slow them down and cushion them for that
last little moment before they
hold their breath for a little bit
longer that rocket booster
uh has touched down we're just waiting
for the capture we can just see it on
our screens now
kate and a lot of talk about jeff bezos
being on this flight he's taking all the
headlines but i want to talk about wally
funk
um the nearly astronaut that he hand
picked to go on this flight tell us
about her story because what a
remarkable day
this is for her absolutely i mean
she i don't think you could have picked
a better person to be on this flight she
has waited
longer than anyone else to become an
astronaut
she trained uh was as part of the
mercury 13 which was an unofficial
program
uh it wasn't a nasa program but they
they did all the same it was a group of
women who did all the same psychological
and physical tests
to see if they could become astronauts
and then it was decided that because
they were women
they wouldn't be able to go to space and
i've heard that she
actually beat john glenn in all of those
tests
um but she wasn't able to go to space
and of course he did he flew up in 1962
so that's you know that's how long she's
been waiting
and today she's beaten him again by
becoming the oldest person
to fly to space so i'm absolutely
ecstatic for her
and you know just just watching her you
know dashing up the stairs to the launch
pad
you wouldn't guess that she's 82 years
old she's just
vibrant and brilliant and yeah i don't
think it could have been a better person
on that flight
oh that's a great story isn't it
straight out of a hollywood movie who
knows
someone may buy up the rights because
they've just written the ending uh for
it today we're just watching the capsule
uh come into land kate and how nervous
is this bit
or is this the sort of safest part of
the whole
trip well now we've seen the
now we've seen the parachutes come out
i'm you know i'm not too worried about
it
um but i i have i have heard this it
described well the soyuz landing where
they also land on the ground
it it has been described as a a
car crash over a waterfall but they you
know that's depending on
oh there they are that i can just see
that they've just landed um
just a couple of seconds behind you
they've kept their seat belts on
hopefully because they're just coming in
to land because like you said that is
literally coming back to earth with a
bump
absolutely yes so you don't glide down
like you would do in a space shuttle
but as a cosmonaut once sent to me said
to me
this is the most romantic way to do it